[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to
all your bible questions this broadcast
is a previously recorded episode
to receive any of the bible resources
mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's
seven four 800-835-6747 now here's your
host from
amazing facts international pastor doug
batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
and laura moore wasn't willing to let go
of the title without a fight
the arizona woman had climbed tanzania's
mount kilimanjaro
the tallest freestanding mountain in the
world a few years back
becoming the oldest woman to summon it
at 85 years of
age but then she found out that another
older russian woman
climbed the 19 000 foot peak and that a
man held the record for the oldest
person to climb it
so not wanting to settle for second
place on july 12
2019 at 89 years of age ann
lorimore returned to tanzania and scaled
kilimanjaro again
unassisted with seven others in her
group to witness the record
ann says there was a point when i was
really concerned because i fell and
broke a rib a few days before i started
up the mountain
i had great pain in my side and couldn't
take deep breaths
but she pushed through the pain with
prayer and deep breathing
making the trip in nine days to become
the oldest person
of any gender to climb the mountain you
know the bible says with faith and
determination
you can conquer mountains stay with us
friends we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
hello listening friends welcome to bible
answers live and we invite you to
call in with your bible questions and
the number if you have a bible question
is 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
and we invite you to call and we're also
streaming on the internet
and uh that's the doug batchelor
facebook page
or the amazing facts facebook page or
the amazing facts
youtube page if you want to see what's
happening here in our studio
we're now we've moved into a new studio
we're soon gonna be on
television with the program and
you can give us a call this is a live
international interactive bible study
and we invite you to call now good
chance you'll get your question on the
program tonight
if you call in my name is doug batchelor
my name is john ross good evening
friends and pastor doug
let's start the program with prayer dear
father we thank you they were able to
take some time to open up your word and
study together we want to ask your
blessing upon this program you are those
who are listening
scattered across the country and even in
some other countries lord and
lead us all into a clearer understanding
of what the bible teaches
for we ask this in jesus name amen amen
pastor you opened the program talking
about a person of incredible
endurance and determination 89 year old
anne
climbs mount kilimanjaro there's not too
many people that can boast of
climbing mount kilimanjaro let alone an
89 year old that is just incredible
i know i i think i'd be out of wind if i
went up that high going 19 000
feet and uh yeah back down again
and it's just uh not only you're
climbing the mountain but just
the environment in which you're climbing
it's humid it's hot you're walking
through jungles and part of the mountain
then you're getting up into the higher
region where there's
snow and cold and just quite the um
you've got the full gamut of climate
that you have to adjust to as you climb
that's quite an accomplishment you know
last year
uh during the you know when kovit was in
full bloom
um you know i used to live in the
mountains in a cave
and it was pretty rugged it's an 11 000
foot mountain
and i had not been up there in years i
hadn't climbed up there in 20 years and
my youngest son had never been up to the
cave where i
found the bible and found the lord and
and so i said all right now
nathan it's now or never and so uh with
uh
an old friend from my teenage years the
three of us hiked up there and boy i'll
tell you i was
i barely made it it was it was pretty
rough i don't think i could make it up
in 19 000 foot mountain so this is
impressive for me
but it makes me think of what uh you
know what jesus said
that several times he talks about if
you've got faith you can move mountains
you can say to this mountain be plucked
up and cast into the sea
and when jesus talks about faith
sometimes he uses the word faith
interchangeably
with believing and also persistence
christ said when the son of man comes
will he find
faith on the earth and he tells that he
says that right after he tells a story
about persistence
endurance he that endures to the end
the same will be saved god wants us to
have a faithful that will hang on
like jacob and not let go and so uh with
that faith
uh you can conquer mountains it might be
a mountain of sin but he'll cast it into
the depths of the sea
and then he sets up a no fishing sign
now we've got a free offer pastor ross
that talks about
how a person can strengthen their faith
we have a book we haven't offered this
for a long time but it's a great book
written by
pastor doug it's called who do you think
you are it's got an intriguing title but
it's talking about
faith and how do we exercise a living
faith how do we have the right
thoughts or the right attitude and we'll
be happy to send this book to anyone who
calls and asks
again the book is called who do you
think you are the number to call for
that is 800-835-6747 that is our
resource phone line
again that's 800-835-6747
the book is entitled who do you think
you are we'll send it to anyone here in
north america
if you have a bible related question the
phone line to the studio
is 800-463-7200
one more time 800-463-7297
we're going to go to our first call of
this evening uh we have
josiah listening from florida josiah
welcome to the program
hi hi
my question is um
malachi chapter 1 2 to
3 it says that
that
why did why did god hate
esau but he loved jacob
when god loves everybody
good question you're really thinking
josiah i appreciate that
well when the lord talks about jacob and
esau
in malachi he's not talking about the
brothers jacob and esau he's talking
about
their nations so the the nation of
israel
is named for jacob that was one of his
names was israel
and the lord loved the people the
descendants of jacob because they turn
to god and they worship god
but the descendants of esau turned away
from god
and that's why god says look i've i've
redeemed
the israelites which is jacob
but the people the the
descendants of esau
they were destroyed by their enemies and
so
he loved both jacob and esau the people
but the nations turned away from him the
turned away that's what he's
really talking about here
okay thank you for your call josiah
we've got uh let's see uh wanda who's
listening from
british columbia uh wanda welcome to the
program
hello hi how are you doing yeah so
i'm so great to uh i mean it's so great
to be able to ask you guys some
questions here
uh yeah let's see how we do
i'm curious what's the question i'm sure
you'll do great um
my question is it's in luke 22 36-38
okay and the question is uh jesus
and his disciples were together and he
he was talking to his disciples and he
said
uh if you have a cloak sell it and buy
some swords
and the disciples said here we have two
swords and he said it's enough
yes and all right let me read verse 36
and
through verse 37 because you have to
kind of get the whole context here
so jesus is saying in verse 35 he said
when i sent you without money bag or
knapsack and sandals did you lack
anything
they said nothing he said to them but
now he who has no money back let him
take it likewise a knapsack and he who
has no sword let him sell his garment
and buy one
for i say unto you that that which is
written must still be accomplished in me
and he was numbered with the
transgressors of course christ was
executed between two thieves for the
things concerning me have an end
they said lord look we have two swords
and he said it is enough
now that phrase it is enough not does
not mean that jesus thought with two
swords
that they were going to overthrow the
roman empire
i mean obviously with two swords they
weren't even going to overthrow the
guard that came to arrest jesus
because when peter pulled the sword
jesus said put your sword away
he that lives by the sword will die by
the sword
so the sword is a symbol for the word
remember jesus said i came not to send
peace
but a sword and he's talking about his
word and he was telling the disciples
you need to be really
prepared with the word because you're
going to be tried for your faith
as many of them were and be able to
defend it
and so you know this is really what he's
talking about here and when he says
it is enough uh the way that translates
more accurately
he's saying enough of this and what that
means is that he's they said look lord
we've got two swords he's going ugh
enough of this you don't you guys don't
get it it's like when jesus was crossing
the sea of galilee with the disciples
and he said beware of the leaven of the
pharisees
and the disciples said we forgot to
bring bread again he's telling us about
the leaven and jesus said you don't get
it
i'm not talking about leaven and bread
i'm talking about the teaching of the
pharisees
so christ often spoke in metaphors and
symbols and
when he said you know he that has a
garment let him sell it and get a sword
he wasn't talking about that he's
talking about being equipped with the
word
you know uh one we've got a we've got a
book that we'll be happy to sing you
it's all about the word of god
and the bible does speak of the word as
being a sword the two-edged sword
the book is called the ultimate resource
and it talks about the bible and we'll
be happy to send this to anyone who
calls and asks
the number is
the book from 800-835-6747 facts called
the ultimate resource
it's all about the word of god about
that sharp two-edged sword the bible
speaks of
that can transform a person's life
thanks for call wanda we appreciate it
we got caitlyn listening in arizona
caitlyn welcome to the program
hello and good evening pastor evening
all right so i understand that the
earthly sanctuary was set up as a
replica of the heavenly sanctuary and
that we believe jesus to be in the
heavenly sanctuary now
in your seating on our behalf does the
bible say anything or do we have any
idea as to what will happen to the
heavenly sanctuary after jesus returns
and the saints go to heaven
well we know that immediately upon the
moment when he
begins the return the bible tells us in
revelation there's
silence in heaven for the space of half
an hour and i think another place that
says no man could enter this temple
because basically intercession has
stopped the saved or saved the lost or
lost
and that's in revelation 22 he that is
clean will stay clean still he that is
filthy is filthy still
everyone is sealed one way or the other
for eternity um
so the sanctuary is still there
technically
now when you say sanctuary keep in mind
it represents
you've got sanctuary temple tabernacle
they're sort of interchangeable they
it represents the dwelling place of god
but
we've got the sanctuary where we know
that it was outfitted with
an altar of incense a laver
an altar of sacrifice once we enter
eternity
there's no more sacrificing of lambs no
more interceding for sin
but there is still a dwelling place for
god
and it talks about in revelation that
the the water flows from the throne of
god
you read in ezekiel and it says that the
water flows from the temple meaning the
dwelling place of god
but pastor ross has another verse that
uh talks about there being no
temperament yeah
it is interesting that um after the 1000
years as you read about in revelation
chapter 20 and the earth is recreated
which is revelation 21
you find in revelation 21 verse 22 this
is after the earth is created
new it says speaking of the new
jerusalem but i saw no temple in it
for the lord god almighty in the lamb or
the temple thereof
so it appears as though the function of
the purpose of the temple that of
redemption has finally met its
completion there's no need for
a temple at least the temple services we
understand it now
but of course there still is the
dwelling place of god so it does seem to
change
at least having a temple here after the
1000 years
it speaks of no temple inside the new
jerusalem
and what it says yeah and when and when
pastor ross was just quoting the lord
god as the temple remember when jesus
was on earth and i forget where this is
pastor ross and john
where he said destroy this temple and in
three days i'll raise it up but he spoke
of his body
and so that's another verse that
parallels with that thank you caitlyn
that was john chapter 2 verse 19 pastor
doug that
actually we find that in three of the
gospels mark 26 61
uh sorry matthew 26 61 mark 15 29 and
john 2 verse 19.
it mentions the same thing where jesus
says destroy this temple in three days
i'll raise it up but he spoke of himself
we've got glenn listening well ron
actually ron in tennessee ron welcome to
the program
uh good evening and uh how are you guys
doing wonderful thank you for asking
good
[Music]
um i was in a discussion a few days ago
with friend dealing with the nephilim
and the sons of god
mating with the daughters of
man and creating giants
and my friend's belief was that they
were
angels but uh i don't believe that they
were i think
that they were like the offspring of
seth
anyway
i need biblical proof
showing either that the sons of god
are referring to earthly men
and not angels or some
indication that angels do not have the
ability to procreate
all right well for one thing if he's
referring to genesis 6 where it says the
sons of god saw the daughters of men
that they were fair
let the bible interpret itself and you
look in first
john chapter 3 and he says behold what
manner of love the father has bestowed
upon us
that we should be called sons of god
and as many as believed in him to them
he gave power to become sons of god
there's several verses that talk about
believers are referred to as sons of god
so
the descendants of seth and adam and eve
they continued to worship god there by
the gates of the garden of eden
cain left and he turned his back on god
he was a marked man and his
posterity they turned away but you know
he may have had some beautiful daughters
and granddaughters and
great-granddaughters he lived hundreds
of years
and um when as long as they maintained
distinction when the
descendants of seth called the sons of
god did not
intermarry with the daughters of men
there was holiness
but when they saw that they were fair
and they intermarried then the next
thing it says
is that wickedness was great in the
earth i think pastor ross might have a
verse for jesus said angels neither mary
yeah i'm looking at the verse here
matthew 22 verse 29 actually verse
30 where jesus says verse 29 he says
you must you're a mistake and not
knowing the scriptures or the power of
god for in the resurrection they neither
marry nor
give any marriage but are like the
angels of god in heaven
now the context of that is being married
but having children
or heirs and angels don't marry they
don't procreate there's not little baby
angels
um in spite of the medieval pictures you
know i was just thinking of little
cupids
with wings floating around uh no that's
not biblical it always talks about the
angels it says like
concerning lucifer god says in the day
you were created
he doesn't say you're born never does it
refer to an angel's being born
and you never see angels getting older
getting younger dying they're always
forever
the same they're ministering spirits we
are flesh and blood
spirits do not inter-interact or uh
co-procreate with the humans there's
nothing else in the bible that says that
so
i think we got to stick with the the um
interpretation that really makes sense
and you see this theme all the way
through the bible
when the children of israel began to
intermarry with the pagan nations then
they lost their identity it's the same
thing that happened in genesis
you know pastor i'm just trying to
remember i believe we have a book called
who are the sons of god
yeah we do and i think that answers
everybody aliens angels are adopted who
are the sons of god
yes so ron if you want to call for that
there will be a lot more bible verses
and um
i think you'll find it helpful in your
discussion with your friend
the number is
ask for the book called 800-835-6747 are
the sons of god and we'll send that out
to anyone in north america and as we
always say if you're listening outside
of north america
you can go to the amazing facts website
you can just read it for free right
there online just type it in
and you'll be able to read the book
thanks for call glenn ron we have glenn
now
in ohio hi glenn welcome to the program
thank you for taking my call sir listen
some of the bothersome things in bible
study are what i call
cover words like hell is a cover word
love is a cover word and tonight i'm
concerned about the cover word soul
they talk about the immortality of the
soul yet in the ezekiel
we have the word soul it says the soul
that sitteth it shall die
there's some confusion there can you
help me
yeah well uh the only one who
has immortality is god and i think it
also says that in
timothy pastor ross might find that word
says god
only has immortality to him alone has
immortality
so eternal life is given as a gift to
those who believe whosoever believes in
him should not perish that means die
but have everlasting life so those are
our two choices that of course is john 3
16. and so the word soul some people
think the word soul
you know always means you've got this
ethereal ghost that floats in and out of
people
the bible calls a person a soul
it's just when adam when god made adam
he made the
dust of the earth he formed into a man
then it says he breathed into that
being and he became a soul
when a person dies you've got basically
creation in reverse
you read in ecclesiastes that when a
person dies the spirit of god the
the gift of life goes back to god who
gave it the body turns to dust
and stops being a person until the
resurrection when god
again breathes his spirit into these
resurrected creatures
you know the verse referring to the
pastor is first timothy chapter 6
15 makes it very clear speaking of god
it says he
alone has immortality dwelling in an
unapproachable light
so immortality is found in god now we
obtain
immortality by receiving christ it is a
gift of god but we do not have
immortality in and of ourselves
the wages of sin is death and the bible
makes it clear uh the end result for
the devil and his angels and for the
wicked is eternal death
does that help a little bit glenn you
know i would like to see them do
something about the confusion between
the word soul
and i agree with you know in genesis 2 7
it talks about became a living nephesh
which is a creature
and doesn't have anything to do with
your spirit but that's the body
but yet it also talks about the part of
the souls being that
immaterial kind of it's just confusing
they use the same word for two different
things and
yeah well i i think you're you're on the
right track
is sometimes in the bible when it uses
the word soul it's talking about the
character the essence of who you are
and i think there's even one past that
talks about body soul and spirit
he uses the word spirit and soul
together and it's just saying that
your character the whole person because
you know your thoughts are something
that
is sort of spiritual you can't a doctor
you can't say doctor i want you to take
a thought out of my head
like he might take a wart i mean uh it's
there's something
supernatural or spiritual about our
thinking and
the bible uses that word sometimes to
talk about your character and who you
are
you know we do have a study guide past
the doug that will send to anyone
uh if you just ask for it it's called
are the dead really dead and it talks
about this
and the number to call is
four 800-835-6747 and again just ask for
that study guide it's one of our
uh classic amazing facts study guide
series
it's called other dead really dead and
we'll put it in the mail and send it to
you again 800-835-6747
we have nana listening from north
carolina
nana welcome to the program
thank you thank you for having me yes um
how are you folks doing doing good thank
you for calling in good i have a
question
and i i think my question is coming from
um job
uh chapter four um and actually begins
from
12 all the way to 18
when joe one of joe's friends came to
him
and you know pretty much trying to make
a case that job has seen
and if you read from 12 it says now a
word was secretly
brought to me and my ear receive whisper
of it
in this quiet and taught from the
visions of the night when deep sleep
falls a man fear came upon me and
trembled which made all my bones shake
then as spirit passed before my face the
hair on my
body stood up is too still but i could
not discern its appearance the foremost
before my eyes
there was a silence then i heard a voice
saying can a motive
be more righteous than god can a man be
more pure than his maker
if he puts no trust in his servant if he
charges his angels with arrow
now um that section is is
is job's friends is is a dream
more like his thoughts going to bed or
is it more sort of like you know
um uh god gave him a vision and he
alters those words or is it like you
know that spirit that he says has no
form isn't right you know
just the devil giving the idea so he can
blame job
or kind of like you know discourage joke
yeah let me jump in here real quick
because you've uh you've read several
verses
and uh this of course is from as you
mentioned for those who are listening
job 4
starting with verse 12 through 18. and
it's the comments of eliphaz the
temanite
and he's a friend of jobs these are all
three
men of respect and renown i think they
were well intentioned because they were
job's friends
the big place where they got wrong is
they thought joe
was suffering because of his sins
because
technically it is true not always but it
is often true
that you know god rewards wickedness and
there's punishment for that
so eliphaz may have had a vision he may
have had a revelation from an angel or
god that told him shall mortal man be
more just than god
because joe what he called not job
abraham actually uses
uh something like that he says well not
the the
king of the earth do what is right and
that's when he's interceding for a lot
so i think there's a chance that god may
have spoken to eliphaz but he's
misapplying this experience
and he's basically saying job you know
if you're suffering you must have done
something wrong
and you just aren't aware you're hiding
it from us because how could god punish
a person the way you're suffering
unless you had sinned and even solomon
says
though a sinner seems to prosper i know
in the end it will be well
with the righteous but it will not be
well with the wicked
and so in the end even job prospered god
double bless them
you know pastor there's an interesting
verse here in job 42
verse 3 and this is after all of job's
friends speak and then finally
job speaks and then god responds to job
and then job says lord i understand you
could do all things
he said i heard about you with my
hearing but now my eyes have seen you
and i repent
but then god says this is very
interesting verse 7 and it says and the
lord has spoken these words to job
that the lord said to alphas
the tamanite my wrath is aroused against
you and your two friends for you have
not spoken of me
what is right as my servant job has so
apparently
they misrepresented the character of god
to some degree yeah
and again probably as you mentioned they
thought that job was hiding some
terrible sin
that he was suffering for yeah and that
was not correct
yeah i think that when you read the book
of job and you read the things that are
written by
oh eliphaz bildad the shoe height i
can't remember the name of the third one
but
there's four actually four characters
that show up in the book of job
you can't take the chapters written by
these guys
and throw them out and say they are not
inspired because in principle these guys
are saying
things that are true generally but their
big sin was
judging job and misapplying it and so
but you know there's a lot of average
things that they say that most people
would say well yeah that was true
and because i've seen people take three
quarters of the book of job if job isn't
saying it they say it's none of it's
true
and so there's there's a balancer but
they had not
done the right thing in uh saying that
it was
uh job was suffering for his sins
but anyway hey you know uh we're gonna
take a break i'm looking at the clock
36 35 34 not enough time
to uh take a question before the break
we're not done so if you're standing
online
don't go anywhere we're going to come
back in just a moment and do more bible
questions and answers in the meantime we
might want to just mention a couple of
things that are coming up
we're gonna have a program on amazing
facts television called
amazing sanctuary that's coming up soon
you go to the amazing facts website
you'll find out more about that
that's amazingfacts.org we're going to
catch our breath and take a drink of
water
back with your questions in just a
moment
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
you know the most important decision a
young person can make is that decision
to follow jesus and begin that amazing
adventure to eternity
that's why we're so excited to tell you
about the new amazing adventure
programs that are available during these
nearly 10 hours of exciting high
definition programs
the young people will do science
experiments learn about history
nature encounter some wild animals and
most of all
they'll learn about jesus from the word
of god there's a beautifully illustrated
bible study guide
to go along with each of the video
presentations these beautiful
illustrated study guides are full of
pictures and puzzles and bible stories
they'll lead your kids through an
incredible journey with jesus
and for me the most exciting thing is
this new amazing adventure series
goes along with the amazing facts
adventure bible the bible
the study guides the dvds are all
designed
to lead your young person on a journey
for life with jesus
contact us at afbookstore.com
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive and probably telling stories
about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major bible events
and characters
enhance your knowledge of the bible and
draw closer to god's word
go deeper visit biblehistory.com
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aftv.org
at aftv.org you can enjoy video
and audio presentations as well as
printed material
all free of charge 24 hours a day seven
days a week right from your computer or
mobile device
visit aftv.org
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
god and his plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode
if you'd like answers to your bible
related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 p.m
and 8 p.m pacific time to receive any of
the bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back
listening friends
this is bible answers live and i am doug
batchelor
my name is john ross and pastor we've
got some folks waiting who have
called in so we're going to go to the
phone lines we've got henry
listening from bronx new york henry
welcome to the program
uh yes how are your blessings
uh i want to know whatever happened
to the shroud when veronica wiped
christ's face before he went to the
cross
uh i was at the front panel procedures
they had a copy of it it was in a glass
case
what happened to
all right that's a great question you
know um there is a popular
artifact called the shroud of turin that
is in italy today and uh you know it's
been much disputed and much
examined it is rather unique in that it
almost looks like a negative photo image
of some man's body
that had been in a shroud and it's like
some explosion of light came from the
inside out and
just created this this image and
of a man that they figure was about six
feet and there's blood on the shroud and
different places for the hands and the
head
and they've done carbon dating and it
may actually be
somebody who was crucified but they say
that the carbon dating they do
doesn't come from palestine and it dates
back
to i think 1200 a.d
so um you know i'm just i'm just
repeating what i've heard the news
there's no reference in the bible of
veronica
wiping jesus face that's a tradition
that has come down
you don't find anything any reference to
that in scripture
so who knows you know the cloth that
jesus was buried in you know some people
they say if we could only find the holy
grail the cup
that jesus offered at the last supper
and
there have been crusades to find this
this
elusive or mysterious um
cup but it's not not referenced in the
bible what happened to it
i mean as far as we know that they
washed it and put it away with the other
dishes afterward and
lost track of it so i don't know that
the disciples were going around saving
artifacts of jesus
you know i understand that there's a lot
of churches around the world say we've
got a piece of the cross
or we've got one of the thorns and
they've got all these artifacts and you
start adding them all
up and they've got enough splinters of
the cross to build several crosses
in the churches around the world so yeah
i don't know i think the most important
thing is not an artifact but we have a
personal relationship with a living god
who will talk to us right now
amen that's an important thing thank you
henry we've got janice
listening from florida janice welcome to
the program
hi hello how's it going
i'm great i'm glad to hear you guys god
bless you
i love what you do i listen to you every
night and go to sleep
thank you i put a lot of people to sleep
well thanks for tuning in and your
question okay so my question is for
genesis
chapter 19 verse 30 through
32. i wanted to know why was lot afraid
and uh to go to zore
i'm sorry to say this is to say azor and
why
did the sister you know when they slept
with their father is that something that
was the
will of god how do you think that view
um
knew that okay so for insects
that's something that today in today's
eyes and guys
like today that happens that goes on can
like incest marry and go to church
and be christians is that something that
god would allow
all right well you've given us some good
questions to work on here first of all
when
lot fled with the angels urging
out of sodom gomorrah he started out
with his wife and two daughters
god said don't look back the wife looked
back now whether she was walking in
front of lot or not we don't know but
they must have known or seen she turned
into a pill or assault
and that put the fear in them now god
had said don't go to the cities go to
the mountains
and so when they first went into zoar um
it may be then when god rained fire and
gomorrah a fire and brimstone on sodom
and gomorrah
it's so terrified then because the bible
says even abraham saw the smoke of the
country going up like a furnace so
picture a mushroom cloud like a nuclear
blast coming up from
these cities and here lot is thinking
man maybe i better not stay in the city
look at what happened to those cities
and at that point he thought this the
end of the world he fled up in the
mountains with his daughters
his daughters thought it was the end
that this destruction was so
catastrophic they didn't know if every
city in the world had been destroyed
and so uh that's when the daughter said
there's no man left in the earth we
better procreate with our father just
like you know
adam and eve now that would be incest
and back in the days of adam and eve if
a brother married his sister
adam and eve were technically brother
and sister there was no incest then
but as time went on then god said
brothers and sisters shouldn't marry
ultimately cousins should not marry
now today in some states cousins are not
allowed first cousins aren't allowed to
marry and some are
but you know we know there's genetic
problems when they do that
and i think moses goes through this
little litany and i forget if it's in
exodus or leviticus
i'm actually yeah i'm looking at a
pastor leviticus 18 he goes through the
list of
closest kin that could not get married
you couldn't marry a sibling and
so on and so forth so um yeah i think
you're right
even today modern science will tell you
that if you marry too close to the
family tree you could have genetic
issues with your children so
god knew that and he created those those
guidelines those rules
all right well thanks for calling we got
ruby listening from baltimore ruby
welcome to the program
thank you thank you for the opportunity
to ask questions
oh so oh i read the
genesis as we know god the item
and eat and they put them in the garden
and then told them not to eat the food
from the tree of knowledge
so my question is that at that time
satan was already cut
out of the heaven so with the potential
of the
competition you know from uh satan
and also god created you know them with
free will
so there is a potential that they are
going to eat the food of
a tree of the knowledge of that you know
that
exactly what happened so my question is
that is that part of
god's plan to test them
yeah well you know god knows all things
and he knew
that uh it well he knew what was going
to happen
but god gave his creatures freedom and
see i think the reason
that god had the tree among
a few reasons is because he did not want
the devil to harass
them and follow them around the garden
and around the new earth
he said there's only one place where you
can test or tempt
this this new world and these creatures
and that'll be at that tree
and i've told them not to eat from the
tree and
so that was where the devil you know he
took the form or he uh in
what he called it he uh possessed the
serpent and then tempted them there
but um you know god wanted to make sure
that
all the creatures in the universe had
were choosing to love and serve him
freely
lucifer was challenging that god was a
good god and a loving god and so
god basically said i'm going to give
lucifer an opportunity to make his case
for all these unfallen worlds
unfortunately our world fell our first
parents and we
inherited that uh genetic defect of
selfishness
instead of love and all the sin you see
in the world
is the outcropping of that now you know
ruby we've got a dvd called
cosmic conflict that talks a little
about this and you can probably watch it
for free
just by going to youtube thank you
have you seen that before just if you
just type in
that's part of the revelation now right
yeah well it's actually a separate dvd
but if you type in
cosmic conflict into uh just
google it or youtube and you'll see i
think they've got all
the episodes there it's like a 45 minute
or one hour
presentation we also have a study guide
that's called did god create
the devil and we'll send this to anyone
who calls and asks it does deal with the
subject of if god is good
how did the devil turn out bad number to
call is 800-8356
you can ask for the study guide it's
called did god create
the devil we've got robert listening
from
college place washington robert welcome
to the program
hi pastor ross hi pastor doug hi
um my um i guess about a half hour
or so ago the young man almost told my
thunder as i was wanting to speak about
dead people too
okay um but
my question i don't know if it makes
sense or not
or if it's silly or whatever you want to
call it but
since i talk to people online people who
believe
that your spirit continues after you die
kind of thing
i was and and one person brought up one
of the people
brought up uh what's the difference
between the holy spirit
and in the spirit of the dead kind of
person i mean
you know they they believe that a person
has a spirit
and so then what's the difference
between between the holy spirit and like
an angel is called the spirit
and then a spirit of the dead i mean
all right good well you know
understanding the words helps a little
bit robert
and the word spirit in greek anyway is
the word numa
and we use that a lot in our it's
talking about air or wind
and when it talks about the breath of
god in the old testament it uses the
word roach
which means breath and so the word
spirit you
jesus said you know the wind blows where
it will and you can see
it moving things but you don't know
where it came from or where it's going
and so you're going to find it talking
about
angels or ministering spirits they're
not tangible where you grab them they're
you know they're angels in the room
where you are right now and there's
angels in our room right now in this
studio
um the holy spirit of course is god
and it's this person of the godhead that
is
ethereal and omnipresent and speaks to
every mind and heart and can influence
every creature and that's completely
different
realm than you know when we say the
breath of life a person has
or that uh you know the spirit that is
in man
we have a book that deals with this very
subject it's called
the trinity and we'll send this to
anyone who calls and asks and
yes the holy spirit is the third member
of the godhead and it's very different
from
angels but we'll have to send this to
anyone who calls an ass the number is
800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for that book
it's called the trinity
is it biblical we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks
thanks robert we've got ann listening
right here in roseville california and
welcome to the program
did you say your hand yes you're up oh
sorry that's okay um hi hi there i'm
hoping you guys are doing well
um i'm calling in regards to revelation
11 and it's in regards to the two
witnesses
um i know that from three it talks about
they will prophesy for twelve hundred
and sixty days
and but and then continues on and saying
that um they will um uh
they'll be finishing their testimony and
on number seven talks about
um the beast that comes up from the
abyss will attack and overpower them and
kill them
so i'm not 100 positive um you know when
they talk about the prophesizing
uh for 1260 days and then the
the beast coming up i'm trying to figure
out the timeline
and and what about these two witnesses
that's talking about
good yeah good question uh first of all
very simply the two witnesses are the
word of god
sometimes they're um pictured as moses
and elijah because moses
was the great lawgiver and elijah was
the great prophet and
jesus often refers to the word of god as
the law and the prophets
and these are the two characters that
appeared to jesus on the mount of
transfiguration
in mark chapter 9 and other passages
and so there is a war against the word
of god for 1260 years a special war
against the word of god
during the dark ages so this is a
prophecy about a war against god's
peop god's word but it is it goes
through a special intensity around the
time
atheism is born in france where
the word of god is actually outlawed and
they burn bible bibles in the street and
they
massacre christians and they try to go
from a seven day week to a ten day week
to try to get rid of any vestige of the
bible
and for three and a half years a day in
prophecies a year so not three and a
half days three and a half years
the bibles were outlawed now france went
into a terrible
economic downturn and
they finally readmitted the bible
allowed it again in society
and it was exalted it's like it was uh
caught up to the heavens and
in sight of all that's a quick overview
yeah you know pasadena is an amazing
study but
france was the first nation openly to
of the european nations to proclaim
itself atheistic which had never been
done before
and then of course you had the terrible
revolt that took place and people turn
against the bible and they piled them up
and burnt them in the streets
you had voltaire who declared that god
was dead
but the amazing thing is after 1798
after the french revolution
three and a half years they legalized
the bible once again
and after the death of voltaire the very
printing press that he was using to
propagate atheism was eventually used to
print bibles in multiple languages
sent by the missionaries in the early
1800s literally
around the world so the bible was
elevate and that's where it talks about
the two witnesses being lifted up into
the air
so just a really great study and we do
have a book that talks about the two
witnesses
it's called the two witnesses moses and
elijah and we will send this to anyone
who asks and i think
and you'll really enjoy reading that the
number to call for that is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book it's
called two witnesses i think it's also
called the glorious mount the two
witnesses
okay yes sir that's probably a newer
title i got the older one here so yeah
the glorious mountain thank you pastor
doug
and you can also see that online just go
to the amazing facts
website you can read that um
lorna is our next caller from sacramento
lorena welcome to the program
oh hello hi thank you for taking my call
my sons have been um listening to
uh bastard dog for a long time
especially amazing
adventures they will be like that and
so one of them is um
asking because a close family member
tells
us that in order to obtain god's
blessing
we have to bless the jews
and he's quoting god bless those who
bless you
and of course evangelicals support
the building up of israel and insist
that gentiles
owe it to the jews financially
and for me i give offering
to the church that blesses me and i
don't feel like i have to also
give an offering to the jews but
how i don't know how to how do you
respond to that
yes yeah well you know it is true i
think that god has a special
plan for the jewish nation and i always
want to let people know that i can't
really answer this objectively because
i'm
i consider myself jewish my mother was
jewish and i find being a christian you
don't have to forsake your judaism
you know i consider myself more jewish
than they've ever been after accepting
the jewish messiah
but the bible tells us
in the jewish book that god is no
respecter of persons
meaning that you know once we come to
christ that we're to love and respect
every person i do believe god still has
a special plan for the jewish nation but
i don't really find a scripture that
says the gentiles now are supposed to be
sending money
to the nation of israel and
i think we're to pray for the peace of
jerusalem that doesn't just mean literal
jerusalem i think we're to be praying
for the peace of god's people
and that's called new jerusalem yeah i
think of an example pastor
there was a terrible famine in the
region of judea this is in the time of
paul
and we find that paul traveled to some
of the gentile churches
and an offering was collected to help
relieve the suffering of
the christians most of them jewish in
judea or in the area of jerusalem
it was not just an offering that was
given in general to the jewish people as
a whole but it was
in particular to help support jewish
believers in christ because they were
also facing some persecution so
you know the new testament new testament
makes it clear that if we are um
believers in christ then we are
abraham's seed heirs according to the
promise
right so it's not your your genetic
makeup that determines whether or not
you're a jew but spiritually you become
a jew
by receiving jesus yeah was it galatians
3 28
there once you're in christ there's
neither jew or gentile that's right
slave or free
male or female we're all one in christ
okay thanks for your call we've got uh
jeffrey from
new york jeffrey welcome to the program
oh hi
hi doug batchelor thank you for calling
my question
yeah thank you for answering my call my
question
for you guys is does the bible say
anything against rings for marriage
well i'd actually ask that a different
way do you find
a scripture anywhere that talks about
rings for marriage
and my answer would be no there's no
scripture that talks about wedding rings
that's something that kind of grew out
of customs that
uh it found its way as far back as they
can tell it found its way
loosely from babylon to egypt and then
made its way through the
the middle east in the jewish weddings
there was nothing about wedding rings
and there was nothing in christian
weddings it wasn't until much later
that that kind of became a signal
of marriage closest thing i can find is
that
when eliezer came to get a wife for
isaac he brought a dowry
and in the dowry that he gave to rebecca
they had jewels of gold and silver
never mentions a ring for the hand but
it talks about
it talks about a nose jewel and
bracelets and it so that was just part
of dowry money they used to pay
they did not have paper money they did
not have coin money the money was jewels
when the children of israel left egypt
it says the egyptians had to pay them
for their work and they paid them by
giving them
jewels and some of it was earrings and
nose rings and
and that's what they used to make a
golden calf later
so so you're i guess you're asking does
the bible say anything against it there
what's that verse there is one verse
that's in
isaiah chapter 3 and it talks about the
daughters of israel
the tinkling of their jewels and i'll
take away the bravery of their ornaments
so there are some passages that speak
loosely about
jewelry or i should say generally about
jewelry and they're not positive
but you don't really find anything that
is supporting or against the wedding
rings in the bible
because it just wasn't in the bible it'd
be like asking me what does the bible
say about tobacco uh
well it doesn't say anything it wasn't
an issue
yeah the verse you're referring to i
think one of the verses is isaiah
chapter 3 and verse 20
talks about all of the decorations and
adornment that
was prevalent in israel and god says i'm
going to take this stuff away
yeah you know and of course we find a
time of revival that occurred during the
time of jacob
where um they buried all of their idols
and their jewels
and went to present themselves retreat
yeah yeah
okay well thanks for call jeff we got uh
heather listening
in canada heather welcome to the program
hi thank you for having me uh taking my
phone call
i had a question concerning
the tribulation period concerning it
was what hope does the bible give us
for our family and our friends and our
children
for everybody in general um because it
found a
a variable a very horrible time
and i was looking for hope okay well
don't worry
uh you know if you know you're saved the
only thing i
worry about so to speak is the bible
says work out your salvation with fear
and trembling every day i want to make
sure that i am
in christ and uh you know paul said i
die daily
and we want to daily deny ourselves take
up our cross and follow him don't worry
about the future christ told us over and
over do not fear do not fear do not fear
he said yeah there'll be tribulation in
the world not just in the end of time
but every believer experiences some
tribulation there's trouble that comes
into everyone's life
christ said be of good cheer i have
overcome the world
now there is going to be a great time of
trouble at the end of time and there'll
be plagues that will fall
that's the great time of trouble that i
believe you're talking about heather
but keep in mind when the children of
israel were in egypt
when the plagues were falling the last
seven plagues did not
fall on the children of israel there
were ten plagues that fell on egypt
god protected the israelites from the
last seven plagues
and since there are seven plagues in the
end of time in revelation
is that what chapter 15 16 i trust god's
going to protect us
we don't have to worry about the last
plagues well you know pastor doug we
have a verse for that and it's a great
promise
psalm 91 verse 9 let me read it it says
because you have made the lord which is
my refuge even the most higher dwelling
place
no evil shall befall you nor shalt any
plague come near your dwelling
for he shall give his angels charge over
you to keep you in
all your ways now if you read up a
little bit earlier in that same passage
it makes it clear that this is during a
time
of widespread destruction verse 7 says a
thousand will fall at your side ten
thousand at your right hand but it will
not come near you
only with your eyes you shall look and
see the reward of the wicked so this is
clear judgment coming
a reference to the seven last plagues at
the end but we do have the promise that
if we make the lord our refuge
no plague shall come near our dwelling
god will take care of his people
yeah so don't be afraid heather you
don't have to worry
there is tribulation in life uh paul
in acts 14 22 he said strengthen the
souls of the disciples exhorting them to
continue in the faith that's the key
continue in the faith saying we must
through many tribulations
enter the kingdom of god and so yeah
there's there are troubles there's
persecutions there's challenges you're
going to have health problems sometimes
there's
personal or you know interpersonal
relationship problems um
and the lord uses these these things to
try us but
god never wants us to live in fear he
wants us to live in faith
and he wants us to live in joy you know
it says the joy of the lord is your
strength
hey you know i've got a book that you'll
enjoy i just finished a book about worry
and uh it's talking about uh freedom
from worrying so if uh if you'd like to
get a copy of that you can go to the
amazing facts website and you can learn
a little more about that i think you'll
find that encouraging i've got some
friends that just worry worry worry
and so i wrote a book on it and of
course we'd like to remind you of our
free offer for today it's a book
entitled who do you think you are
written by pastor doug
if you'd like to receive that the number
to call is 800-835-6747 again just ask
for the book who do you think you are
pass today we have just a little less
than a minute you mentioned uh on the
break about an upcoming program
april the 2nd yes we've got something
exciting that begins april 2 and it's
called
amazing sanctuary and you will see it on
af that's amazing facts television it'll
be streaming also on the amazing facts
facebook page
the youtube page i believe the doug
batchelor youtube page our facebook page
and uh we're going to have a number of
speakers in myself pastor ross
carlos munoz james rafferty
don mackintosh stephen bohr it's going
to be just a weekend that is
action-packed and we're going to be
looking at this incredible subject of
the sanctuary the tabernacle the temple
that's found from genesis to revelation
in the bible and the secrets that it
tells us about salvation
so go to the amazing facts website
amazingfacts.org
and sign up now for amazing sanctuary
you'll be blessed and we'll study his
word together again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you
understand your bible even better than
before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay
california
[Music]
the bible tells us that salvation of
course emanates from god
so we need to know something about god
to rightly understand and embrace
salvation
yet in the church today there's a great
deal of confusion about the nature of
god
the bible says god is one god but is he
three persons
is jesus also eternal god because jesus
is the son of god does that mean there
was a time when he did not exist
or he was brought into existence is the
holy spirit a person
or is he just the force and the energy
that god uses to communicate
you know i thought this was so important
i really felt led of the lord to write a
book on the subject
called exploring the trinity one god or
three
in this book we answer those very
important questions we talk about the
history of the holy spirit in the old
testament
as well as the history of the holy
spirit in the church and how it has been
much debated
this is something we really need to
understand because jesus said
eternal life comes from knowing god
journey back through time to the center
of the universe
discover how a perfect angel transformed
into
satan the archvillain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet
and the first humans witness the
temptation in evil
discover god's amazing plan to save his
children
this is a story that involves every life
on earth
every life
the cosmic conflict if god is good
if god is all-powerful if god is love
then what went wrong
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
[Music]